Hey guys,
Jason from jubilee project here,
and we're so excited to see him about
two weeks at Jubilee Conference on August
15 but before we continue, we want to
make a big announcement. Check it out.
So guys,
this is Jeremy Lin.
I can't wait to see you guys at the
Jubilee Project Conference in August.
I'm excited. So you guys said, yeah,
we're showed say to have Jeremy and he's
going to be joined by an amazing group
of other speakers,
and they're all going to be sharing
about what it means to take the road less
traveled. So we're super, super excited
that if you haven't done so yet,
please register now.
You can go to this link or the
link below and register today.
Seats are going quickly. We think we're
going to sell out soon. So go to it now.
Tell your friends and we'll see
you at the conference. Jp luff.